bella adulti ragazzi e prevenuti questo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo arrivati
al [ __ ] giorno della live
mica è un mese che dico che avrei fatto
sta live venderà casuali allora la rives
alle 4 di oggi pomeriggio adesso sono le
leve presto per l'ultima volta se volete
partecipare alla diretta live che farò
tra poco quindi se volete giocare con me
apparire nella live i link dei giochi
che andrà a fare solo nella descrizione
di questo video scaricateli preparatevi
che tra poco mi connetto alle 4 alle 4
ci sarà la live quindi alle 16 tutti
quanti con gli occhietti ni sul monitor
che ci sono io che sbuccia le banane
quindi ragazzo che ci vediamo tra poco
vado a prepararmi che che che non so
proprio messo bene vado a prenderla e
banane così mi preparo già e noi ci
vediamo alle 4 da ragazzi
[ __ ] partiamo bene per questo
pensa in live che cazzo succede
beh ragazzi